[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on this Thursday the 2nd
of February 2023
my name is Freddie gray and I will be
your host today
on the show this week we will be asking
the same question as the cover of The
Spectator this week how will the war in
Ukraine end I will be talking to Owen
Matthews and Dimitri trenan about that
difficult and important question
and then we will move on to talk about
reality or should I say transsexualism
and the nature of reality with none
other than the great Rod little
and after that we will talk to Douglas
Murray and Heather McDonald about police
violence in America
and lastly I'll be talking to Toby Young
about his finding out thanks to Big
Brother watch that he's being spied on
by the British government for his daring
to question lockdown policy
before we get to any of that I must
thank our brilliant sponsor Khanna
called genuity wealth management can
Accord our wealth planners and
investment managers who offer unwavering
support in these challenging times visit
can do wealth.com for more information
next month uh we'll mark the first
anniversary of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and the front cover of this
week's spectator asks the question how
will it end it's obviously a very
difficult question to answer but a very
important one
I'm joined Now by Owen Matthews who's
the spectators Moscow correspondent and
Dimitri trenan who is at the higher
School of economics in Moscow formerly
of the Carnegie Center Owen you say in
your piece that we are not in the end
game yet of the war we are
still probably what might be called the
middle game
and you conclude on a rather gloomy note
I don't want to give away the ending but
I will
um you say tragically There is almost no
realistic outcome for the sport that
will not end in the ukrainians crying
betrayal uh can you explain your
argument yes well I I very much hope
that I'm wrong uh but I fear that I'm
not
um uh the main point of the piece is
actually to point out two things that I
think are somewhat underappreciated
um both in Kiev and a monkey of
supporters in the west and those two
things are that there are parts of
Ukraine as constituted after the fall of
Soviet Union namely Crimea and the rebel
Republic the self-declared rebel
republics of the donbass which really
are very strongly anti-kiev and any
scenario has the ukrainians now say is
their scenario for victory that involves
taking those areas is involves a
different kind of war and it's a war
that will suddenly be seen by the vast
majority of the locals Who Remain it's
important those who remain because those
who are pro-kiev have fled donbass
they've been terrorized and bullied into
interfleeing but the people who remain
in Crimea and the Russian occupied parts
of donbass are actually we'll see that
as a war of conquest and aggression not
a war of Liberation and that's a really
serious moral and strategic problem for
the end game of the war and the second
point that I wanted to make is that
actually I think it's underappreciated
the extent to which uh unfortunately for
the ukrainians and for the the prospects
for peace Putin still has enormous very
profound reserves of military
and capability he's suddenly running out
of high technology high precision
rocketry and modern
tanks and so on but Russia really hasn't
really gone to anything like a fully
mobilized War economy yet and that also
bodes rather rather badly um for the
spring offensive or the early Springer
spent offensive that we're all expecting
Putin to to mount I think that
unfortunately Putin and Russia remains
much stronger than the west and
certainly the ukrainians tend to
appreciate
um but you would you would you would bet
that the sort of stalemate or ongoing
struggle will be the the dominant part
of the next phase of this conflict
well the problem is that
um I mean I certainly didn't have a
crystal ball and I'm not going to get
into the into the business of
predictions but
um the problem is that any piece that
involves exchanging land for ceasefire
or land for peace is politically fatal
for zielinski or indeed any Ukrainian
leader we can debate whether you know
the the ethics of that
um you know of of whether Crimea and
parts of the donbass should be given
away but clearly that leaves a very
major moral hazard it rewards aggression
it leaves Putin a kind the capacity to
declare some kind of Victory I mean a
hollow victory pirick victory that's
certainly true so there's a huge moral
hazard there but the problem is that
when if it comes to the alternative to a
land for peace deal is a sort of Forever
War
and if a Forever War is going to be
fought on the money on the resources um
on The Guns of the West
and um there are also questions about
the solidity of the Western Alliance I
think there are cranks that are going to
appear and I think cracks that are going
to widen unfortunately as the war drags
on
Dimitri uh Owen in his piece suggests
that zelenski is in a more precarious
position a lot of people might think
um what about Putin's position I mean we
talk a lot in the west about Anis and
the Kremlin dissatisfaction uh with how
the war's going
um are we slightly blinkered in the way
we look at what how the Kremlin is
thinking what's going on with Putin
uh well frankly uh I think that's the
case at least that's how I see it
um I believe that despite the initial
um disappointment that uh quite a few
people experienced in the first weeks of
the war or of the special military
operation
the uh majority vast majority of the
people have
focused on um supporting the operation
uh wedged by their soldiers
and the Putin as a commander-in-chief
um has the ultimate responsibility of
course and in a situation like this
uh pointing to the mistakes made by your
commander-in-chief is essentially
helping the other side helping uh the
enemy helping
Russia's adversaries uh Beyond Ukraine
so Putin's um popularity uh if I may use
the word I think the better word to use
would be support is uh fairly high it's
uh that's historically
uh very high level of support
so all those uh uh rumors about uh uh
Elite dissatisfaction uh true but only
to uh to a certain point uh there were
quite a few people who were connected
with the West materially
emotionally but mostly materially these
people uh understood that uh because of
this operation they were losing a lot of
money and they essentially uh wanted the
war to stop as soon as possible and they
wanted to be able to rescue at least
some of the money that was at risk in
the west the West Was confiscating Not
only Russian Sovereign assets or
Sovereign currency reserves but also
private assets of Russian citizens
but this never reached the level of the
top Elite or or the elite if you like
that that rules the place
um it is uh extremely dangerous I would
say even for those people who are
somewhat dissatisfied somewhat uh uh
doubtful uh to uh show their disloyalty
so I think the elite is um
very much
uh United in in their support for Putin
and the population at large sees this
war increasingly not as Russia's war of
aggression in a foreign country but
rather as Russia's push back against the
U.S led uh
efforts to use Ukraine as a uh as a
staging ground for operations against
Russia well I I wonder about that
because clearly the war has has not gone
uh successfully for Russia so far
um but would you argue then that in
terms of grander global strategy uh it
is going according to plan because of
this you know World majority China
Brazil uh India other major countries
are moving away from the american-led
order towards a more multi-polar world
and that is part of Russia's plan that
Ukraine will will act as a sort of lever
to shift the world in that direction
well I think frankly uh it's um call it
Plan B but it was no plan b the original
plan as I understand it was to help uh
internal Ukrainian forces some political
quarters plus a portion of the Ukrainian
military
to topple the zelenski regime and
um
take over power in Kiev
and then that would be the end of the
operation that would be that would be no
war that would be a special operation I
think that was the way it was designed
the Russian strategy has uh has has only
begun I would say with the failure of
the initial plan which did not survive
the reality check so now you have to
strategize now you have a very powerful
enemy
uh you have uh even more powerful uh uh
backers of that enemy who sit in various
Western capitals
uh you uh have to uh to rely on the uh
support of
uh of uh uh essentially you only have
yourself to uh you lie upon uh all the
rest of the non-western world are
essentially taking a neutral position
and um well some of them are more
sympathetic to Russia others are less
sympathetic some of them are more afraid
of U.S
um uh secondary sanctions and and and
pressure and others are less afraid of
that but essentially uh Russia is on its
own and I think that uh most Russians
realize now that
um however this uh present war in
Ukraine may end the hybrid War the
broader war between Russia on the one
hand and the collective West on the
other hand is likely to continue for
maybe a couple of decades
um you say in the piece as I mentioned
earlier the zelinski is in a more
precarious position
um than many think
how precarious is his position I mean
Putin as you say has room to maneuver
are you saying that zelenski is is
almost stuck now
well zielinski is tremendously popular
because he's been an extremely effective
War leader unexpectedly so and he's
actually extremely impressive in person
and he enjoys enormous amounts of
support including from parts of
Ukrainian society that uh that hated his
guts is his his opinion poll ratings
were around 30 before this War I mean he
was really you know on the political
skids but he has proved and surprised
everybody including the Kremlin by the
way who thought he was just like an
actor and an idiot and a sort of puppet
he's been extraordinarily impressive as
a war leader prime one of the main
reasons one of the main things that he's
been very impressive about is rallying
about that Western support that has
allowed Ukraine to fight but the reason
why his position is ultimately very
vulnerable is something that we touched
on earlier is that actually there is no
realistic end game
that that fulfills his stated definition
of victory so right at the beginning of
the war zielinski actually broadly
hinted in fact said that you know we can
compromise on full major membership and
actually broadly hinted that the status
of Crimea and donbass was up for
negotiation there with you know with
plebiscites and so on on the condition
that Russia Russian military returned to
its pre-february 24th borders he's now
moved away to a very much more
aggressive position partly because he
now thinks that he can has a chance of
winning the war I've actually been
taking Crimea and donbass and I
personally think that that's not only
militarily extremely unlikely but
actually politically dangerous because
it involves you know creating a
revolutionary situation in Russia
essentially that's one reason and
secondly it involves fighting a
population that actually doesn't
necessarily want to be Ukrainian so
those are the the so so there are two
major elements of zelinski's Victory
plan that are essentially unachievable
so in that sense he's somewhat painted
himself into a corner and in Practical
terms you know if Putin comes to the
table and saying you know we are going
to we're willing to have a ceasefire and
we're going to take x amount of
Ukrainian territory and zielinski is
obviously going to say no and that
process is going to come go on for a
long time but you know whichever way you
cut it the I I think the most likely
outcome is ultimately some sort of land
for peace deal which I've already said
is actually going to be totally fatal
for not a new zealandski but for any
Ukrainian leader to sign
to be tributing uh Russia's
Russia since the invasion Russia's the
chances of a sort of European
europeanized Russia have have dissipated
that Russia is now effectively isolated
from the West
um is there any resolution to this
conflict foreseeable or imaginable uh
resolution to this conflict that would
involve Russia not uh turning its back
completely on the west and the West's
not turning its back completely on
Russia
well I think the West has turned its
back on Russia
um frankly I do not see uh the West uh
returning to the posture Visa the Russia
that it held let's say before the start
of the uh Ukrainian
uh crisis back in 2014. so I I just
don't think I I think that the changes
in places not to speak of Poland and the
Baltic states but the changes in places
like uh Germany uh or uh the the Czech
Republic uh the Scandinavian countries
including Finland are just
um colossal and uh things will not come
back to uh to where they stayed back in
2012 2013. with regard to Russia I think
what this war is doing is closing books
on the first post-soviet edition of the
Russian state
uh which which tried to be uh integrated
uh into the West with the West it wanted
to be in NATO it wanted to be closely
tied to the European Union it passed the
Constitution that had France and Germany
for models its Elite was
um very much focused on uh on Europe and
the United States they had second homes
in places like Miami
um
uh called dazur and London of course but
uh but this war and it had the the the
the elite that was
um you know very much focused on uh on
Western uh pop culture mass culture and
the youth were very much uh uh in that
category too and I think that this is uh
this is over
what I think Russia is embarking upon is
uh is totally unknown
it's essentially seeking to
reinvent itself as a state civilization
self-contained self-sustained
um
Northwestern not Eastern uh something
like you know uh the global North
that sits between the west and the East
and has the South and it's uh underbelly
and it plays a role in that emerging
global
um distribution of power
that has uh so much more in common or
that is so much closer to the roles
played by non-western Nations and
domestically again Russia I think is is
um that already the process already
started just before the
or rather through in the period between
14 and 22. uh the process of rewracking
the Russian Constitution the process of
coming up with a set of values the
process of rejecting the novel values of
the West in gender politics in um
uh
um uh family relations and you know all
these all these new things that
traditional Russian culture uh clearly
Rejects and this is where Russia is
moving to again I don't know whether
Russia has passed the point of no return
but I think that Russia is definitely
walking in that direction and the war
has been the uh the most powerful
impulse that set Russia on that path
oh and I wonder what you make of that I
mean clearly Russia is uh still a very
large and powerful country but it's
economy is uh is is not tremendously
developed in many ways uh the its Army
has not uh shown itself very well in
this latest expression of hard power if
it does want to be a civilization of
North is it not going to struggle and
perhaps become uh really a kind of a
part of a Chinese an emerging Chinese
Empire
well I think uh I mean dare I say this
on The Spectator podcast but actually it
has something in common with brexit
um it's it's the sort of fully to go
under it's a sort of post-imperial
country that thinks it's much more
bigger and more important than it
actually is I mean in fact Britain as it
happens is bigger economically and more
important than Russia in fact but I mean
Russia's economy is you know depending
on how you measure it but certainly in
in in dollar terms uh it's actually uh
around the 9th or the 10th it's roughly
the same as as Italy's or Canada's uh if
the dollar if the ruble collapses then
it just sort of tumbles down to sort of
Mexico South Korea levels so um the GDP
of Russia is 30 times less not three
times less but 30 times less that of the
collective GDP of NATO and it's these
these fantasies that Russia is actually
sort of a major Global civilization that
can stand on its own and actually detach
itself from you know both culturally and
and economically from the Western world
is just you know a delusion it's just
it's a delusion born of you know a long
imperial history and certainly of a
recent history of living memory when
basically the Soviet Union was the peer
of America and certainly the in a much
senior and more powerful to China but
that understanding is actually you know
a generation or two old it's out of date
and furthermore um I mean the the
Russian economy hasn't really started to
collapse because there was a huge spike
in Energy prices over the summer but
actually as we've seen in October
already sorry in in December already you
know wholesale gas prices in Europe fell
to October 2021 I.E pre-war levels
um Brent um Euros crude is trading at an
enormous discount actually around 45 to
55 dollars a barrel and they're selling
it via sanctions busting you know
through through India and China but
nonetheless with a production cost of 40
two to forty five dollars a barrel
Russia actually isn't making any money
off it's very little money off its oil
it has no one to sell us gas to he used
to sell 180 billion cubic meters a year
to Europe that's now gone down to about
30. it's selling 12 billion dollars a
year to China because it doesn't have
the pipelines to expand uh its capacity
to China its position as a global energy
so not only is the sort of the basic
premise of that sort of Russia standing
alone as a sort of great Global
Standalone civilization flawed but also
the practicalities of it are actually
going to become you know more and more
apparent because I suspect that there's
actually going to be a very steep
decline in the Russian economy so
they're actually
um and then what are you down to you're
you are indeed as Mr training
brilliantly said I mean it's you're
you're you're then down to the level of
Someone Like You Know countries like
turkey or Iran which has it have
enormous Regional nuisance value they
have powerful militaries uh but you know
that's in no way comparable or appeared
to the countries that you know Putin and
the Russian Elite think that they are
appeared to I.E the American and the
Americans and the Chinese it's sadly
based on a fantasy
oh and Dimitri we better end it there
but uh thank you very much for coming on
we didn't answer the question how we'll
end but that was an impossible ask uh
but that was a very interesting
discussion thank you
uh Nicholas sturgeon and transsexualism
have been in the news once again
uh is the Scottish national party facing
up to what happens when ideology
confronts reality Rod little has
explored this question in his column
this week a typically brilliant column
Rod joins us now uh hello rod
the only major uh can you start by you
start with the strange allegory of uh
Chicken Little Renard to Chicken Little
could you take us a little bit through
gallery for people that haven't read the
column
yes it's a it's a it's a it's a nursery
story really isn't it um uh Nursery tale
it's about uh a fox called Raynard who
notices that a job is going very good at
a local Chicken Coop and changes his
name to uh Chicken Little in order to
secure this up uh employment opportunity
uh and convinces the board members who
interviewed for the job and who consist
of members of the Scottish national
party uh that he should have the job
largely by kind of sellotaping uh red
plastic wattles to the bottom of his
chin
um and the wattles were you bought the
wattles he got the wattles from a
Christmas cracker and of course he's
given the job until it is revealed that
he's done this ruse before and eaten an
entire Coop of chickens
and so there's a certain kind of few raw
and indeed the Scottish national party
uh uh interviewers decide actually
shouldn't have this job uh you must go
and live amongst foxes and do your work
amongst foxes
and then they extend that to all other
foxes uh deciding that whilst those that
identify as chickens undoubtedly are
chickens for some undisclosed reason
they are not allowed to live in chicken
coops uh or take up a employment
opportunities therein
and No One Believes any of this nobody
nobody I don't believe for a single
moment that any members of the Scottish
national party uh who are morons
um
believed that uh that uh double rapist
was a woman now I don't think anybody
does the rapist didn't believe he was a
woman his ex-wife didn't believe he was
nobody believes he's a woman the
biologists don't believe he's a woman
you know he's not a woman he's a he
uh and so this absurdity is played out
to the detriment of the SNP so we should
obviously welcome this story uh because
it has shown awoke agenda as being
uh an insane ideology a genuinely insane
ideology which
is very very easily
um
revealed to be to be that to be an act
of lunacy
and as you say some sporting bodies are
now confronting reality and accepting
that trans women can't well yeah I mean
that's the point Freddy isn't it that
that
all the institutions which actually live
in the real world
um have seen that this is is an
absurdity
um so more and more sporting bodies are
now deciding that uh what they call
trans women and what the rest of us
would call the men
um should not be taking part in
um the competitions against women uh but
and they do that because they realize
that if that if that were allowed to
happen we would see an end to women's
sport pretty quickly it would all be you
know uh rather hears you'd uh bearded
ladies in not terribly well fitting wigs
uh winning cycling races and swimming
races and and wrestling bouts and so on
um but I suspect as I said in the piece
I suspected that still if you asked the
the uh the the the corporate leaders of
these institutions if that meant that
they thought that someone who
transitioned to being a woman was a real
woman they would say well yes of course
they are they would perpetuate the same
downright
easily disprovable lie they would
continue to go along with it
well this brings us back to what we
talked about last time we had you on Rod
which is uh the trouble with truth at
the moment and relativism in that you
can you can say one thing is true one in
in one instance and it can be the
complete opposite can be true in a
different instance uh I mean isn't the
bigger problem that nobody really cares
what's true
yeah it's double sink um and people are
unable to do this double thing because
say sign up to an ideology which has no
rationality which is post-rational that
there is no logic to it no rationality
to it
um and of course it's made easier to do
so uh by the by the fraying bonds of
what we call truths uh so that these
loads of people who subscribe to this
ideology this idiotic and demonstrably
uh lunatic ideology uh will
disavow rational inquiry and empirical
inquiry and insists that their truths
and my truths is the only thing that
matters
um thereby uh uh kind of
uh obviating any possible
rational inquiry into the idioces that
they think
Rishi sunax government has uh picked a
fight sort of uh with Nicholas sturgeon
the s p over this and politically it
seems like quite a sensible thing to do
do you think that uh the Tory party uh
are wise to pick these fights do you
think they actually are willing to deep
down uh and do you think they will win
these fights
uh they're certainly with them uh but
they haven't picked anywhere near enough
of them if they picked more of these
fights uh and particularly on the race
issues and decolonization and all that
sort of stuff they would win them and
they would win more public support and
they would put secure starmer in a very
very difficult position as uh indeed
because sakir of course still doesn't
know what a woman is uh and he's still
act to sort of Bob down on one knee
whenever the feeling takes him uh and
all these uh expressions of Madness
which come from this this ideology uh
are antithetical to the vast majority of
people in the country and the
conservatives can only gain by
exploiting them but as matched against
that you have to say that we've had a
conservative party in power for 12 years
13 years nearly and uh it is under that
party that these things have thrived uh
it's done to that party that the
Tavistock Clinic was allowed to go ahead
and mutilate children and
The Stonewall was able to spew its
odious propaganda into the nation's
schools
and the police officers went down on one
lead to the to the uh thugs from BLM
which I believe means uh by larger
Mansions I'm not sure I forget what the
actual phrase is so so you cannot trust
the tourists to do this you cannot trust
the tourists to to especially when there
are
um prominent conservatives who are
genuinely afflicted by the same lunacy
of Starman such as the LDS Carolyn Nokes
for example well I was going to say that
a lot of Tory MPS are very uh nervous on
this issue or even inclined to say uh
the opposite of what's obviously true
and real
um I mean why is it when there's
obviously a good electoral incentive to
do it uh they can put themselves on the
side of what most people think and what
a lot of people are angry about and yet
within Westminster within the the sw1
bubble there is this uh allergy to it
well sure I mean the most important
thing to say is that these people are
hiding from the truth
um
and that's the first and most important
thing on the Electoral side of things we
are ruled by liberal Elite Freddie you
know and have been it was the same in a
sense with brexit uh now there is no
good I'm not trying to argue that brexit
is as is anywhere near as
straightforward as uh
as the trans issue and and uh and BLM
and so on it clearly isn't I mean um
brexit could have gone either way and I
could have voted either way but
nonetheless if you looked at if you look
at the House of Commons at the time of
the brexit vote it was something like 80
in favor of remain
um we are led by a liberal Elite and the
liberal Elite has values which are not
remotely shared by the vast majority of
people in the country I mean frankly if
I was Carolyn Knox or Justin Greening or
anyone of that I'd uh joined the liberal
Democrats so I'd go and join uh Velma
from Scooby-Doo in the liberal Democrats
um
because you know they are they are not
conservative
well some people uh are joining parties
like the party uh you're a bit involved
with the sdp uh others are joining
reform because they feel that on these
cultural issues that people are very
concerned about the only people willing
to talk in real Common Sense called
normal truth terms truthful terms uh are
outside of the the unit party for one of
a better word of Laboratory
no that's exactly right that's exactly
right so the sdp does indeed you know
have a very clear line on this it
doesn't wish for transgender people to
be subjected to hostility or intolerance
but it it will not go along with
something which is just plainly and
obviously a lie uh and I believe the
reform uh I haven't spoken to Richard
tells recently but I assume Richard
thinks exactly the same way
um uh but as I say you know our
institutions are captured by this bubble
have been captured by this bubble the
BBC you know the the universities uh and
the quangos the Charities they are all
captured by the same absolute idiocy and
the newspapers you know it is it is
bizarre to read
in a right-of-centered newspaper
um this particular rapist uh being
referred to as she it is just bizarre
um they they seem to they they
understand clearly
that it's an absurdity that that uh that
he was allowed into a woman's prison
but they are incapable of addressing
their own inability
to understand why it's an absurdity I.E
that is a man you know it is utterly
bizarre
well I suppose that's language is the
key thing there isn't it I mean it is
once you attack language you can
dismantle the truth
yeah that's that's exactly right the
language is important
and the language is important
the way the newspapers present the
language is is crucially important if
even newspapers such as a Daily
Telegraph
are able to refer to men as women simply
because the men wish to be women then
then it is very very difficult for the
forces of rationality and empiricism and
and common sense to to muster a proper
defense I mean we play a part in this
and we shouldn't forget that
well Rod I wonder how chicken Little's
uh career is going to end up I think
maybe chairman of the BBC
I would have thought almost certainly
the chicken little
I was trying to think of names of
fictional chickens this is a problem
when you come to write these pieces and
you get this good idea or you think it's
a good idea and then you're suddenly I
have sat sat at this desk for nearly
announcing again
famous chickens and all I could
think of was Chicken Little
and I
which I could have which people would
immediately say chicken
yeah and that's all Jenny
but that doesn't work it doesn't work
does it it you know I mean what would
you have come up with I'm stuck too I
can't I've gone completely blank
uh there's loads for foxes you can have
radar you can have Todd yes well I say
loads there's two
but at least there's two for chickens
what what have you got you know I've got
um I've got nothing I'm drawing no no no
no well that's a problem I had you know
that goes up to 11. it's a major
literary problem
um well thank you very much Rod uh do
come on again soon
now let's go to America where police
violence is in the news again last month
Tyree Nichols uh was in Memphis was uh
pulled out of the car by police pepper
sprayed and beaten so badly that he died
in hospital a few days later
um the police in question all five
police officers turned out to be black
and yet commentators are talking again
about white supremacy uh in regards to
the police in regards to policing in
America I'm joined Now by The Spectators
Douglas Murray and Heather McDonald who
is from the Manhattan a fellow at the
Manhattan Institute I should say
um Douglas you explore this in your
column this week can you explain for
viewers who might be a bit baffled as to
how five uh black police officers
killing a black person is white
supremacy
uh well I mean they're not I'm not
surprised if people are baffled it is
rather baffling
um the the uh family of Nichols and
others had applied for police body cam
footage to be released uh it was
released
um you know a matter of within days of
of of of his death and when it was
released everyone could see of course
that the five arresting officers were
all black and America heaved the kind of
sigh of relief I have to say I think at
that moment
um the relief that you know I mean
America is always only one bad police
interaction from riots burnings lootings
and much more uh so the five officers
turned out to be black and uh
unfortunately for America there is this
prevailing narrative that everything can
be explained by white supremacy and uh
so when the five officers turn out to be
black as like a victim
um these same people just just kept
saying well still white supremacy
um that included the CNN's van Jones who
said just because the officers were
black doesn't mean that this wasn't a
racist killing
but all the way up to the president uh
if you look at the president I cite this
in the article if you look at the the
the rhetoric the president used
President Biden used about it he talked
about how how tired and exhausted he was
this is the language of the modern
movement on this how exhausted he was
and and how exhausted black and brown
people are in America having to see
footage of of black people being killed
so regularly so basically I'm afraid
Freddie although this has nothing to do
with white supremacy much of America is
continuing to pretend that it does
because it has no other narrative
and as you say in your piece that
there's this strange way in which the
British media and in particular the BBC
pick up these stories
um as if somehow they are part of the
British experience of white supremacy
can you say a bit that's right the
American Experience is unique to America
as all countries experience is but in
Britain we import this as well uh we had
guests on American on British television
uh talking about the same thing this was
white supremacy of white supremacist
killing and you know it's very striking
to me that this happens when you know
when there's police violence in France
as there is as there was just again the
other day when they're the anti-pensions
uh protests in in Paris when the French
police brutalized people the British
media doesn't run on it day after day
after day there's something very
interesting about the way in which
Britain is always just in the same melee
as the American culture was these days
Heather uh Douglas I think in your in
his column says it calls it I wish it
was the Civil Rights era racial lens uh
is there something of that going on that
there's almost a sort of nostalgia for
the Simplicity of the of the Civil
Rights era
absolutely and there's been it's tragic
really to OK current civil rights Heroes
Floyd
monuments to him he's got you know civil
rights alleged civil rights laws named
in his behalf and by and large the
people that we are in recent decades are
certainly at least a decade venerating
uh as civil rights heroes are almost
uniformly criminals because the way you
get elevated to the Civil Rights
Pantheon these days is to be abused
as a apparently by a police officer and
the fact of the matter remains is that
to do that you really should be a
criminal if you're law abiding uh and
even if an officer mistakenly tries to
stop you and you comply with his orders
nothing is going to happen
resisting arrest is the key to all of
these sometimes very tragic interactions
but we have very few uh actual civil
rights Heroes today because America as
awful as its past was and I actually
think that conservatives are sometimes
at risk for whitewashing
how gratuitously cruel and sadistic
whites were towards blacks up until very
very recently
it is completely not the reality today
the reality is black privilege not white
privilege however much that was reversed
in the past so I think there's
definitely
a Nostalgia for the
real uh moral
sort of purities of the Civil Rights era
and I would just add you know the one
difficulty with instances like this is
another conservative Safe Harbor is that
if there is a black officer involved in
a contested use of force
conservatives will also breathe a sigh
of relief and saying well
we should put off stage now and it kind
of racism uh presupposition well I would
say we should also put that off when
it's a white officer to to take Safe
Harbor in the fact that it's a black
officer
implies that it's a legitimate inference
uh to say there may be racism involved
if it's a white cop on a black suspect
and I reject that entirely absent
affirmative evidence of racial animus
which we almost never have now we did
not have it in the Derek Chauvin uh knee
on the on the uh
windpipe or neck or shoulders of of
George Floyd
which simply at this point should never
be presuming uh racial animus even when
there's whites involved
um there's a huge uh body of data
there's the The Washington Post has
compiled a huge database on cop violence
uh there's been lots and lots of other
studies and you mentioned them uh in a
brilliant piece that was published
yesterday on spectator World
um I mean the these statistics on the
likelihood of a policeman being killed
being killed himself set against say the
likelihood of an unarmed black man being
killed Again by police are extraordinary
could you tell us a little bit more
about that give us some examples
yeah well this is some data crunching I
did uh the public is completely ignorant
about police shootings about this
so-called epidemic of of police bias
because the perception that we're living
through an epidemic of racially biased
police shootings of black men is an
optical illusion it has no connection to
reality it is the it is the creation of
wildly selective media coverage looking
only at black victims of police
shootings and ignoring those 50 percent
or so white victims of fatal police
shootings every year uh a thousand
overall a thousand fatal police
shootings of civilians about half of
those are white about 25 percent are
black put that 250 victims of fatal
police shootings in context and
virtually all of those victims are armed
violent or resisting uh in 2020 there
were 10 000 blacks killed in criminal
homicides mostly overwhelmingly by other
blacks there's a population of 44
million blacks so the 250 you could get
rid of all cop shootings tomorrow and
that would be a good thing but very
unlikely given the amount of inner city
violence it would have virtually no
effect on the Black Death by homicide
rate but the really critical number is
the number of unarmed allegedly unarmed
blacks uh who are shot by the police and
in 2022 that number was seven now that's
after extraordinary efforts on the part
of the Washington Post to get its
unarmed black number up as high as
possible traditionally the post is
characterized people who are grabbing an
officer's gun as unarmed well I can tell
you if if you're an officer and
somebody's trying to grab your gun you
can assume he's going to use it against
you and that person is should not be
deemed unarmed but if you take those
seven at face value
uh and compare that to the numbers of
police who were killed each year and
particularly by the numbers of police
killed by blacks historically blacks
have made up about 42 percent black
males rather have made up about 42
percent of all cop killers Nationwide
even though black males are six percent
of the nation's population
if you do the calculation on a per
capita basis and there were about 73
blacks excuse me 73 police officers
killed
in uh 2021 you get the fact that a
police officer is 400 times as likely to
be killed by a black male as an unarmed
black is to be killed by a police
officer so the risks in policing are
exactly the opposite of what the
progressive left tells us and the
progressive left loves to say Radley
Balco at the Washington Post always says
oh policing is really safe finding you
know I don't know like the few two
remaining
non-climate-changed Exile miners in the
country and and maybe they have a higher
chance of dying on the job than a police
officer but but the left always says
well policing is a really really safe
job well if policing is safe then being
uh an unarmed black vis-a-vis the police
is 400 times safer
Douglas had the points to all those uh
quite striking statistics that
definitely jar with what we hear on most
the media but I wonder if this is partly
to do with the problem of uh technology
and viral media and so on in that you
can throw as many statistics as you like
but that's never going to compete with
the power or the emotional uh reaction
to a viral video of a man being beaten
to death
well that's true firstly I mean what
Heather says about the optical illusion
is is so true things like the Washington
Post database that both of you have
pointed to You could argue are part of
the problem people who describe
themselves as very liberal think it's
over 10 000 unarmed black Americans who
are killed every year by the American
police so there's in a way the
concentration of effort and attention on
this has has distorted reality and I'm
afraid
when it comes to the international Arena
looking at the us there are simply race
hucksters around the world who want a
bit of this action I give the example in
the in the um in the my column this week
of David Lammy he's not a minor figure
if if uh labor in power he'd be foreign
secretary he's the shadow foreign
secretary at the moment what does he say
after this tape is released but you know
I'm exhausted by having to see yet more
footage of I mean first of all nobody's
making you have to watch you know
horrible police body cam footage of
deaths you know you don't have to be put
through it I don't seek out um body cam
footage of all the black or white people
who who are arrested
um aggressively by American officers any
year but he says I'm exhausted by yet
again it is just it goes to remind us of
you know the threat to black people he
doesn't bother to tell his viewers and
readers uh the the cops in question were
black he doesn't bother with that but he
is willing to play the race card it's
it's a fake uh academic uh huxed doctor
shows something uh who went on Sky my
news the other Data Center Cape early
this killing was because of white
supremacy you know I'm afraid this stuff
is all picked up by um British race
hucksters and others around the world
who simply are doing a power grab on the
basis of this false narrative from
America they point to it they try to
make themselves the Martin Luther King's
or Malcolm X's of their day in the
relevant countries and I'm afraid that
that in in the main and this is one it's
one of the reasons it's such a relief
always speaking with Heather McDonald in
the main in in Britain American
elsewhere the adults have left the room
Heather and Douglas thank you very much
indeed
now let's talk about big brother because
Big Brother watch which is a civil
liberties uh organization
has published a report about government
surveillance of people who are critical
of the government during lockdown one of
the people they were spying on was Toby
Young Who joins me here Toby Enemy of
the State that you are
um how did you come across it you've
written about it this week how did you
um when did you first realize that a big
brother watch might be right well I knew
of the existence of these shadowy
organizations within Whitehall
departments like the counter
disinformation unit in dcms I mean
they're about half a dozen of these
units across Whitehall and often staffed
by former security personnel and for the
most part set up to deal with the threat
of disinformation originally being kind
of used by agents of foreign powers like
Russia and China to destabilize
elections and so forth so seemingly a
legitimate reason for setting them up
but during the pandemic I was aware that
there'd been a certain amount of mission
creep and they were now being used to
monitor supposed disinformation and
misinformation
um being put out by British citizens
about the government's pandemic response
but I didn't think they'd actually go so
far as to be monitoring my activity but
I was contacted by Big Brother watch
about six months ago and they said will
you submit some subject access requests
to these various departments to see if
you were in fact one of the people these
units were monitoring and I didn't think
I would be and I thought it was kind of
pointless but I played along and then lo
and behold turned out I was and I wasn't
the only one you know um uh Peter
Hitchens Julia Hartley Brewer Carl
Hennigan Tom Jefferson I mean a number
of spectator journalists but also some
conservative MPS like um David Davis
Lord sumption former head of the Supreme
Court I mean quite extraordinary how
many people were caught in this
surveillance net one of the
organizations involved on second I think
to dcms was the 77 Brigade which is a
brigade of the British army largely
staffed by reservist which has been
created to deal with these threats to
you know our cyber security but what's
shocking about it I think um is that um
we people like me people like Peter
Hitchens Julia Hartley Brewer Carl
Hennigan are considered you know enemy
combatants enemies of the state
adversaries people that the government
you know has persuaded these various
shadowy organizations to keep an eye on
I mean to to be clear they weren't
monitoring our WhatsApp messages or our
you know telephone conversations it was
all stuff that was in the public domain
but where it gets quite Sinister I think
is that sometimes they would flag social
media posts you know produced by one of
these adversaries
um and uh the agencies would flag it up
as being a breach of the terms of
service of Twitter or Facebook or
YouTube and then they would recommend to
the department in question that they
flag it up use their trusted Flagger
status to then alert Facebook Twitter
Youtube to the fact that so and so had
breached their terms of service in the
hope of getting them banned and they
undoubtedly did that and in some cases
did it successfully they didn't do it in
my case one of the things that one of my
subject access requests uncovered is
that they'd considered doing it in my
case
um uh I think the the the counter
disinformation unit had flagged a fairly
innocuous post on Twitter in which I
pointed out that an anti-vaccine
passport petition in France had 1.2
million signatures apparently this was
misinformation even though it was a
perfectly straightforward factual
account and they said you could flag
this to Twitter as a breach of terms and
conditions but there might be free
speech implications if you did in his
case so it's saying because he's a
fairly well-known journalist and set up
this pro-free speech organization you
might want to think twice about trying
to get him banned by Twitter but other
people I'm sure weren't so lucky weren't
given a pass yes in a way that's
reassuring and it shows that they they
were they were aware that there's a free
speech problem there but at the other
time at that time it's more Sinister
isn't it because because of course you
know let's say you weren't the president
of this free speech Union they wouldn't
have flagged this and and your your
Tweet would have been wiped yeah I mean
and and we know from the Twitter files
that this kind of thing happened in the
United States during the pandemic people
who were critical of the US government's
pandemic response like Jay battachary a
professor of medicine at Stanford
um were were banned or Shadow banned by
Twitter at the request of various state
agencies
um uh and and
um so so I think you know this big
brother report called the ministry of
truth it's really the British Twitter
files turns out that lots of state
agencies here were also using their
trusted Flagger status to contact big
Tech social media platforms and and try
and try and sort of apply pressure not
not kind of demand not threaten them
with legal repercussions if they didn't
but nonetheless apply pressure to ban
people who were being critical of the
government's response I guess the
government's rationale is you know this
was a public emergency and what these
people were tweeting uh could have
harmed public health and in that way
they kind of somehow managed to kind of
Eli the distinction between criticism of
a government's policies and criticism of
something which was in the interest of
the state so we weren't just enemies of
the government it would have been
inappropriate I think to ask these
agencies to monitor the social media
activities of people who were merely
criticizing government policy on party
political grounds that would have been
an inappropriate use of these supposedly
politically neutral you know Personnel
in what working with these agencies but
because they managed to conflate what
they were doing with the national
interest because if you criticize the
government's policies in their view you
were endangering Public Safety they
therefore Justified monitoring People
Like Us or persuaded the Personnel
working for these agencies to do that
and it was it was broad too so it would
have been to where the masking is
effective was one example you mentioned
in your that was seen as questioning
whether masking is an effective way to
stop transmission was seen as
misinformation yes obviously vaccines is
a big topic lockdown policies you know
six where the six people is the
appropriate way of stopping the virus
transmitting yeah you know so they were
applying it to all sorts of things about
which the government didn't know the
answers they didn't have the truth no
but was just branding other things as
you know I mean the government at the
time tried to present these policies as
completely uncontentious scientific
evidence-based policies and therefore
anyone challenging them was a a kind of
science denialist who was who was trying
to endanger the public by by Conjuring
up all sorts of ludicrous reasons to
kind of cast doubt but but actually
turns out they were pretty much making
it up as they were going along you know
they weren't following the science uh
but but that was the narrative at the
time and seemingly it was a narrative
bought into by these various shadowy
agencies only one step removed from the
security services and as you say in your
excellent column
um you know this time it was just about
pandemic stuff and it was a National
Emergency in many ways but there could
easily be a next time and it's not like
these these groups in the government the
rapid response unit they're not they're
not going away the 77th Brigade which is
part of the army uh is not going to
vanish anytime soon they now see
themselves as the Arbiters of of
information and Truth uh it could apply
to another subject uh quite easily no I
spoke to someone a source who
um knows the 77th Brigade quite well and
he said what you should be worried about
is not what the 77th Brigade and these
other agencies did during the pandemic
because they only really monitored stuff
that was in the public domain and you
know the worst that they did was
recommend that the government officials
of these departments contact social
media companies and try to get you
banned it could be much worse he said
um under a labor government let's
suppose kirst armor decides we're in the
midst of a climate emergency
um and anyone challenging The Net Zero
climate emergency agenda
um is is guilty of
um disseminating misinformation you know
he could in those circumstances persuade
these agencies persuade the 77th Brigade
to start monitoring in a much more
aggressive intrusive way people like me
um and you know one of the reasons one
of the things which may have stayed the
hand that people like Matt Hancock even
Michael Gove in the cabinet office when
you know these agencies flagged up that
people like me and Julia Hartley Brewer
and Peter Hitchens were you know
supposedly endangering the public by
challenging mask mandates and vaccine
passports one of the things which stayed
the head might have been that they
actually knew us you know we go to the
same we drink in the same pubs as them
we go to dinner parties with them we've
known them
so that but but we don't have those
sorts of links with the labor party
we're not socialists we're broadly
speaking conservative so they might not
be constrained in that way they might
think aha here's an opportunity to
really skewer someone who's been a
thought in our side for decades so my
real concern is given that the Rubicon
has been cross uh been crossed you know
what will be what will constrain a labor
party government from using these
agencies in a much more aggressive way
against critics of labor party policy
doesn't a lot of it boil down to the
problem of the word disinformational
misinformation because
there's truth and there's lies and
there's stuff in between but
misinformation doesn't necessarily mean
it's not true it just means it's not
approved of right no and I think this is
this is um I mean we see Across the
Western World the concepts of
misinformation and disinformation being
weaponized by state agencies to try and
suppress dissent from government
policies I mean it happened in America
it happened in New Zealand happened in
Canada happened in Holland so that is
now I think a real threat to free speech
and you can actually see how the mission
creep happened in the case of our own
government how do you persuade an agency
set up to combat disinformation which
was originally you know Putin getting
bots on social media to try and
interfere in elections here and in
America how do you persuade them that
you know someone challenging vaccine
passports is guilty of disinformation
well the way they did it was first of
all they decided to classify the
challenge as misinformation that often
just means disagreeing with you know a a
government policy these days
um and then they and then they said it
falls into the category therefore of
Miss slash disinformation so they
created this new category which was a
merger of misinformation and
disinformation and then persuaded these
edges look this person who's criticized
our policy is guilty of Miss slash
disinformation you were set up to combat
disinformation This falls in your
wheelhouse monitor this person
so we will end it there thank you very
much I should probably say uh in case
the YouTube algorithm picks up on this I
disagree with everything you've just
said and it was all Miss slash
disinformation uh but we're very
grateful for you to for coming on I hope
you don't get banned as a consequence
thanks very much
that's it for the week in 60 minutes
from politics to war to chickens to
killer cops and spying governments we've
covered a hell of a lot I hope you've
enjoyed it all and please do tune in
again next week before I go I should
thank once more our brilliant sponsor
kind of called genuity wealth management
they will provide you with the
experience you need to build your wealth
with confidence
thank you very much for watching bye
[Music]